Beth smell that's Beth Beth Smith okay
god it's just such a plain I'm trying to
come up with a mnemonic device true
facts before we release last week's T vs
video for children of more we called
Beth Pam on a couple of occasions it's
hilarious the show thinks Janet's name
is forgettable too I'm so sorry
oh god start why would space Beth to
shoot him if she wanted him to tell your
top bugs the Defiance lives on why not
just write her name down on something if
he can't remember it the product
placement is funny and all but how many
aliens out there would be ones that
would wear jeans and even if they would
Wrangler doesn't seem like the type to
affiliate themselves with
planet-destroying weaponry that really
feels more like a Levi's thing don't you
ever miss her I don't have to miss it
I'm technically still there my dad made
a perfect clone of me to take my place
man Beth brings up the fact that she has
a clone with very little prompting the
question was don't you ever miss earth
and the first words out of her mouth are
I don't have to miss it which makes no
sense but she's able to do a perfect
triple axel from that into by the way I
have a clone I am actually
disintegrating is that really it we did
it I believe Jerry would be gullible
enough to think Rick disintegrated but
none of the rest of the family I don't
even know what this gambit is supposed
to do in a post pickle Rick world other
than to provide the episode with a B
story Morty's making a big mess isn't he
I'm almost certain that the next time we
get a good look at this table we'll get
confirmation of oh it's like nothing
happened at all
Rick probably did something where messes
clean themselves up in some other
dimension or something
Rick creates this grid barrier between
he and Beth but I'm wondering why this
thing doesn't go all the way to the
ceiling why would you create a grid with
this kind of glaring weakness okay wait
what does supposedly clone Beth have in
her neck that allows her to imitate rick
perfectly she doesn't even have a
tracker in there anymore not that it
matters is this how perfect impressions
are possible stick a finger in your neck
even if she had some sort of device in
her throat how does it know to imitate
Rick specifically okay fine this guy
uses military time on his alarm clock
but wasn't it just breakfast like a
minute ago we should still be in the
morning digits right also I will say
it's kind of interesting having the
typical invisible teenage
male uses his powers to be a creeper
peeping-tom switched around to an
invisible woman doing the same thing but
a peeping Tammy would still be creeper
ish so I'm going with a sin regardless
this will only be the second time Morty
has used an invention to spy on girls in
the locker room in the last three
episodes I'm surprised we haven't seen a
Morty Rick possible episode where Morty
tries to spy on the girls by going
through the air vents how do you like
that [ __ ] you mean your old belt that
conveniently had a similar blue circle
on the buckle just like the invisibility
belt did you mean that belt holy crap
what is happening in this picture this
is such a lurid picture that the kid
wearing a meth Gator shirt is the least
insane thing about it I guess Rick and
Morty have a deal with Shoney's too it's
the only reason I can think of that
would possess someone to go there to get
their drink on I feel like this is both
a joke and a product placement like if
we weren't in the middle of a pandemic
we'd mock this but secretly go there
when no one is looking my daughter
having space adventures this packet
sitting by Rick appears to be a pink
sweet and low knockoff and he's drinking
a beer what's that about everybody in
the galaxy tries to take over the galaxy
the trick is to be left alone by whoever
succeeds this coming from a man who is
destroyed no telling how many universes
and even recently impregnated an entire
King planet that sounds like the exact
opposite of laying low
oh look they somehow got Sunnis TV into
the Shoney's the eye was broken off when
Woody Allen threw a baseball at it
during a Ronan Farrow report
I guess summer was just planning on fire
extinguishing the entire locker room to
find Morty but her convenient choice of
this spot is still convenient show gives
me irreversible irreversible flashbacks
if you can find Morty on a random
peeping trip why can't you find his mom
who's actually at the therapists place
at an appointed time the only reason
these guys show up to ask Morty
questions is so that summer and Morty
can overtake the ship in ex machina Rick
out of a bad situation later
tamya pan for a season that is making
fun of sequels rehashes and callbacks
they sure are producing a lot of sequels
rehashes and callbacks susan sarandon
self-appraisal after her first day on
the set of speed racer somehow makes its
way into this episode when rick froze
the beth clone why wasn't he able to put
her in something more permanent so that
this confrontation wouldn't happen Clone
Wars how about I just blow my brains out
starting with hers okay Wendy show makes
a joke about McDonald's just so they can
make a joke about their windi's ads it's
not enough that there's a regular
Wendy's commercial and a Rick and Morty
Wendy's commercial during the broadcast
but yet another mention in the show
itself you know if you're left alone
you're an on threat what how does that
even make the least bit of sense once
again he has destroyed so many universes
and recently impregnated a freaking
planet it's not Citizen Kane but why
compete with whatever's going on here
you know I'm going with Star Wars meets
Starship Troopers meets my stepmother is
an alien what a crappy Death Star does
it really take this long to blow up a
planet the ghosts of Alderaan is pissed
guess the galaxy's most wanted mammal
needs her daddy to come change your
diapy come on kids we have to go do it
in pieces Star Wars which they dropped
the ball on the title of this episode
Rick turn of the Jeri okay but shouldn't
it have been a play on Attack of the
Clones I really want to know how these
portals work exactly because there was a
previous episode where Morty was stuck
with the gun and Rick wasn't in the same
universe and he couldn't figure out how
to get it to work which means it's not
something as simple as thinking about
where you want each portal to lead so if
there is some kind of coordinate code
that means Rick just opened up nine
portals to each of these space bugs
positions by hitting a button on the gun
a couple of times and I'm calling
glub-glub on that looks like summer went
to the fast and furious presents Hobson
Shah School of using a dead or
unconscious body for facial recognition
as I watch Rick once again pull out a
whole bunch of gadgets to get into yet
another fight I wonder why he didn't use
any of this stuff when he fought that
Zeus guy from children of Mort yeah
maybe he agreed on a no weapons
fistfight but Rick doesn't seem like the
kind of guy who cares about the rules of
that some of Rick's extreme body mods
don't even make sense
sure building a panic room for your
heart keeps the heart itself from
puncture but those major entry and exit
are two veins are all still exposed and
in the same general area protecting the
heart muscle itself after a giant drill
has breached the entire chest cavity is
showing effective that it's basically
the pullout method of interior mech
technology some of the pants annex v
can't destroy Wrangler jeans these
product placement things are amusing and
tiresome at the same time they're Tigers
amusing but what I really want to know
is how does one of the guys not know
about the NX 5s inability to destroy
Wrangler jeans maybe we can do like a
Parent Trap thing together sometime as
long as you mean the Lindsay Lohan
version Hayley Mills shaming Rick
survives this this is how I die we're
nowhere near venison you're not a dwarf
in a raincoat don't Rick now it
fascinates me that an entire family can
be this critical and suck this much I
don't even know where to go here the
Kardashians the Vanderpump's the Chris
Lee's I feel like there's one obvious
one that could trump all of these but
I'm at a loss
weekend at Tami's oh come on
Phoenix person has a super obvious
on/off switch on his back why mom and
Terry about your own kids balls also
please understand I am super happy this
scene does not contain Morty balls but
since I'm a sinner I've got to sin
that's what I do
also also hugging your son with his
balls exposed sure cops ready to get the
answers to your burning questions yeah
like where is the family car do they
Park it at the end of the street now
remember clone death is just a cartoon
remember clone death is just a cartoon
just where is this secret room supposed
to be in the house this secret room
would be going directly into a visible
part of the house somewhere just because
you're done with the invisibility belt
doesn't mean you have to throw it away
why would you throw something so
mind-bogglingly useful out for auto the
garbage man to find it
but doesn't the tongue of the belt have
to go into the buckle for it to work and
why would it make the entire truck
disappear when the buckle only be around
a few items of trash and it would make
those disappear if this is the way the
belt works then everything summer and
morty touched when they were wearing it
should have become invisible
not to mention jerry's pee so sit
yourself down at Shoney's for a classic
american shrimp dinner did you know the
cinema said writers have podcast
checkouts in chaos and behind the scenes
by searching for cinemasins where ever
you listen to podcasts I'm Chris Hanson
for one welcome our new insect overlords
Jared do you agree that the use of
puppets makes you seem dumb and crazy
I don't think crazy is a responsible
word to you I said I want you and who is
that
John Cocteau Stone why would you make a
clone of me just to send the clone into
space stop saying Hawaii in there maybe
you should put some shorts on or
something if you want to keep fighting
evil today I like sitting next to you
Sean it makes me look so tough